some of you guys have been asking us to
make a video concerning the apple watch
series 6 that we should be expecting
this fall
and the reason we waited so long to make
this video is because there weren't
really any good leaks and rumors out
there
until now so in this video i'm going to
discuss the expected announcement date
the release date all of the leaks and
rumors we currently have
which features you should expect and
whether or not you should actually wait
for the series 6
instead of just buying a different apple
watch right now let's first try and
figure out when we should expect it to
get released
apple has already announced that the
2020 iphones will launch a few weeks
later than usual
now this is very vague because it could
be three weeks or it could be
five weeks but i think it would be a
mistake to wait too long
and this is very important because apple
always releases their new apple watch
updates
alongside their new iphones twitter
leaker comia
initially posted that the series 6 would
be available to order on september 8th
a wednesday which assumes that's the day
of the september event
and then it would ship on september 18th
which is
the following friday but a few days
later
he then said that the event might not
happen on the 8th
but he's sure that it won't be in
october
however john prosser another leaker
mentioned that he thinks the iphone 12
announcement will actually happen
in october so things seem a bit
uncertain at this moment
he seems to think that they'll go on
sale in mid-october
so this would mean that the event could
take place on october 6th
or the 7th with the shipping date of
october 16th
for the apple watch series 6. i
personally wouldn't expect it to be
any later than that because apple is
also rumored to be having a special
event
for their new apple silicon max and
that's dated for october 27th
so apple wouldn't want those events too
close to each other but there's also the
chance that apple will host the iphone
event sometime
in september and then simply delay the
ship dates
out into october so it's a bit of a toss
up right now
now getting into all the leaks we
currently have right now
there's rumored to be an air power mini
for 99
and the full version of air power for
249 dollars
which will be announced alongside the
apple watch series 6.
and john prosser has mentioned that
apple finally got
the apple watch to work with the air
power wireless charging mat
so that's definitely reassuring and
according to camilla
the airpower mini will be available
sooner with the large air power
shipping at the end of the year now
getting into apple watch specific leaks
some ios 14 code leaked in march
pointing to apple working on a new
blood oxygen monitoring feature this is
a very big deal because a lot of
businesses right now
are requiring people to wear a mask
and these obviously make it harder to
breathe or else they wouldn't be doing
anything
so essentially your apple watch series 6
will tell you when your blood oxygen
level is dropping
letting you know if you should go
outside take off your mask
and get some fresh air and by the way we
actually sell
high quality apple product pattern masks
that are made
in the usa they're very soft and
comfortable
and you can find them in our merch shelf
just below this video
in both black and in white very recently
digitimes reported that apple will add
this feature
to the apple watt series 6. they
mentioned that the new model will
feature
updated bio sensors that detect blood
oxygen
greatly improve sleep monitoring and it
will incorporate an
mems based accelerator and gyroscope
which should be much more accurate
for precise measurements for things like
working out and step monitoring
so as you guys know from apple's wwdc
event
apple is adding sleep tracking to watch
os 7. now my brother max tested the beta
version
and he said it's very limited and it
doesn't work very well right now
so it would make sense that the new
sensors in the series 6 apple watch
will greatly improve sleep tracking now
he also said that battery life was an
issue because it obviously requires your
watch to be on
at night so we should expect apple to
work on improving the battery life
for the series 6. just a couple of days
ago a 303.8 milliamp hour battery was
leaked
which should be destined for the new
apple watch
the current series 5 has a 296 milliamp
hour battery
so there definitely is an improvement
there now don't expect the apple watch
itself to get thicker
because apple did remove force touch in
the upcoming watchos 7 update so that
means they have more room
for a larger battery comedia also
tweeted showing that same battery size
as we saw in that leak
but he also included two other battery
sizes
presumably for the smaller 40 millimeter
size and a model with cellular
now as far as the performance an app
developer who has access to apple's
developer transition kit
for the switch to apple silicon found a
new code
that points to new apple chips including
an s6
chip for the apple watch and since we
know that apple's upcoming iphones
and apple silicon max are going to be
built using tsmc's new 5 nanometer
process
we can expect the s6 chip to be even
more efficient
leading to the same great performance
while getting better battery life
which will help with sleep tracking way
back in november of 2019
ming chakra stated that he believes the
apple watch series 6
will come with a new liquid crystal
polymer flexible circuit board that will
improve performance
water resistance and wireless
transmission which will help with both
wi-fi
and cellular speeds and in august of
2019
apple filed for a patent to enable their
apple watch to come with a new antenna
array
that would allow for a larger range of
cellular frequencies
basically pointing to apple working on a
5g apple watch
now since apple is releasing 5g iphones
this year
there's a chance that we could get a 5g
apple watch
but honestly i think it's a bit too
early because it's going to negatively
impact battery life
and 5g hasn't really seen wide
implementation yet
way back in july of 2019 some sources
claim that the new apple watch series 6
could come with a micro led display
however
leaker love to dream claim that the
series 6 will actually continue
using the same display as the series 5
so it's definitely a toss-up
but in my personal opinion since the
iphone 12 is getting a new square edge
design
and the apple silicon max are coming
later this year
it would make sense for apple to change
up the exterior look or design
a bit to entice users to upgrade since
the series 5
only had minimal changes now there was
somebody who found some new code in ios
14 beta
showing slimmer bezels compared to
before and the removal of the side
button
which could be switched to using a
static haptic button
instead of an actual protruding button
this change would also help with water
resistance
this could also match up to a rumor back
in march that apple is adding a touch id
fingerprint sensor
to the apple watch series 6 which would
work perfectly
in place of the current side button now
if apple did truly slim the bezels of
the display once again
that change alone with the new bio
sensors
might be enough for a lot of people to
upgrade so with all of those leaks and
rumors out of the way
let's talk about whether you should wait
for the series 6 or not well since we're
only a month or two away
i would definitely suggest waiting
unless you absolutely need a watch right
now
and you also have to ask yourself how
much does blood oxygen monitoring
and sleep tracking matter to you and if
not much
then ask yourself how important the
possibility
of a slightly slimmer display is to you
and finally
we should be expecting a pretty decent
battery life improvement
so if that by itself will make the
series 6 worth it for you
then you should definitely wait but if
you think the series 5 does everything
you currently need it to do
and you're not that excited for the new
features then i would consider
picking up a series 5 right now the only
downside is that there really aren't
many great sales going on
with the best price looking like four
hundred and nine dollars on amazon
about twenty dollars off for the 44
millimeter model
and i honestly don't think that the
price will go up much on the series six
maybe a maximum of fifty dollars or it
might even have the same price
so based on that if you can wait then
absolutely wait for the series 6.
if you enjoy this video go ahead and tap
the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe
and definitely be sure to check out our
apple product mask
down in the merch shelf below thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video